today we're talking about networking
revolutions
big news for bigquery and vmware engine
and visual aids
i'm vicola and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news managing and
connecting resources across on-prem
locations and the cloud can get
complicated
with the introduction of network
connectivity center
we deliver global scale network
management to simplify
complex networks for your cloud
connectivity needs
with a single management experience
network connectivity center
serves as a seamless vantage point to
easily create
connect and manage your on-prem and
cloud network
leveraging google's global
infrastructure google has been named
a leader in the forester wave cloud data
warehouse
q1 2021 report
for more than a decade bigquery our
petabyte scale
cloud data warehouse has been in a class
of its own
we're excited to share this recognition
and we want to thank our strong
community of customers
and partners for voicing their opinions
are you looking to learn more about
google cloud but prefer
something with visuals head over to
google cloud tech youtube channel
for a series of whiteboard videos that
explain cloud tools for a tech audience
in about five minutes
with topics from cloud storage to high
performance computing
there's something for everyone if you
have vmware workloads and you want to
modernize your applications to take
advantage of cloud services
to increase agility and reduce total
cost of ownership
then google cloud vmware engine is the
service for you
learn more about its benefits features
and use cases on the blog
and don't forget to check out the handy
cheat sheet too
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a
full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you